and so jesus healed this man
he healed a man that was was a cutter
and jesus can heal you
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
hey everybody good to have you guys with
us today we're going to be talking about
a pretty sensitive topic you may know
somebody or you may struggle with this
yourself
but a lot of people are are experiencing
a lot of pain in their life
and and some people they they try to
escape that pain by causing self-harm
and cutting on themselves they try to
escape the the emotional pain by going
to physical pain
so we're here with chad today he's he's
done a lot of research on this and he's
going to give us some good practical
tips
on how to overcome this and how to help
others and uh
you know i'm excited to hear what you
got for us yeah i'm happy to be here and
if you want to learn more about this
also go to our youtube channel
called health and homestead and you can
see other
things that we share on research on
various different mental health and
physical health
subjects so that's health and homestead
and
the thing that got me more interested in
you know we my wife and i have been
traveling for the last
it's been almost 20 years now and
i've i think there's a real increase
actually even
the you can see it in the popular media
they're realizing that more and more
people
are cutting and doing different forms of
self-harm
especially during covet it is just kind
of a
there's just we don't know 100 why
obviously we know there's more stress
no question uh especially during the
lockdowns during the lockdowns
people are alone they're not
communicating they're not seeing each
other face to face
you only see you know you can't see a
smile
and so there's so many strange things
that have
taken place because of this one of which
is
an increased depression anxiety and
self-harm
and we were just spending some time at a
school and
we were speaking to the high school
and realizing that uh more and more even
boys
are self-harming cutting and so forth
you see this also amongst the young
ladies and so
what are some of the things that we can
do about it before we go into that
i want to talk about the fact that this
is really a very
normal part of human existence not
not healthy necessarily but very normal
so i was thinking back
through the history of planet earth and
one of the things you see is
you go back really i mean the earliest
examples i know of personally are
roughly
2 800 2 900 years ago you had
in canaan in the canaan land you had
these canaanites you had a group of
people who followed
a god by the name of baal and we can
actually see them
even even in connection with they seem
to be frustrated they were within a
worship experience
and they began to actually literally
lacerate their flash they began to cut
themselves so
one of the things we know is that it's
not new this is not like oh this is kind
of like a new
trend or something no this is a normal
part of historical experience you might
be thinking
well maybe they did that in in touch
with their religious experience you do
see
even some religions today will
do that they'll actually there's one
religion that takes swords and they will
cut their forehead
over and over blood will be coming down
and they will do that that's in the
country of iraq a
certain sect of islam does that you look
back through history
to things like martin luther martin
luther the great reformer he was a he
was a catholic priest the catholic
church they probably don't do it like
they used to
uh after the reformation even kind of
changed the catholic church as
you know martin luther was a catholic
obviously and he would he would
they would flatulate themselves they
would actually beat themselves and
and now why would people the world over
including ancient cultures medieval
cultures
why would they do this well one of the
aspects
may be that they find some form of
pleasure
not probably in the pain itself but in
the as the pain begins to go away and
subside you have an endorphin rush and
we're going to talk a little bit more
about that at the research specifically
on that subject but
one particular individual in history
that we see did this
it came to my mind i've heard about this
in the past and i've
actually spent a lot of time in this
book of the bible mark chapter 5 verse
five there was an individual
who was a cutter and it says that this
man he jesus came
he came he was next to the sea he was an
area called
gudera and the people there were the
gaddarians and as he came out of his bow
there was this gadarian who came out to
meet him they're actually
two mark only references one because he
must have been the most prominent in his
memory
or not in his memory in peter's memory
who he shared the story with
and this man comes and it says in mark 5
5 and always night and day
this individual was in the mountains and
in the tomb
so he was living amongst tombs he was
crying
and he was cutting himself with stones
and so this is once again 2 000 years
ago
you go back further we can see
throughout history
we can see humans doing these things and
the good news is with this individual
with that met jesus he ends up
it tells us that he ended up bowing down
before jesus and his life ends up being
totally changed people were afraid to go
into the area
that this man was because of his
outbursts of anger and so forth
but after he meets jesus he finds
victory over cutting overcutting
you you're under like you know the fact
that the bible gives you the little
information that he came out of the
tombs like
like that's where he felt comfortable
yeah you know isn't that kind of
interesting like
yeah like we we think of death and you
know like scary movies
we portray people coming out of the
tombs and it's like this very scary
experience and it's like
that's where this guy was like residing
you know what i mean like
like he was in this dark dark mental
state in his mind
i think that it's a great point and some
of some of the things is as we begin to
feel
more depressed we often gravitate
towards
darker things right you you maybe want
to watch a movie that
is scarier or darker or more violent or
whatever
and so we we have this tendency to do
that same thing you know
like this man he actually moved into and
you think of even
even some of the cultures and this isn't
to insult anybody but is if we have a
culture that is
is thinking about or idolizing death or
darkness or
evil it it shows generally that there is
some kind of
sadness within our lives this is not an
insult this is not to put anybody down
but jesus actually came to this man who
had that exact same experience because
he wanted to give him a happier life
and this man went forth and began to
change other people's lives
and that's the good thing is that if you
struggle with this or you know somebody
that has struggled
some of the simple things that we share
here may help you to be just like this
man who's his life was changed
and then he was able to go help other
people out so
thinking about this uh basically people
psychologists psychiatrists scientists
have wondered
now is there something different about
these people is there something
different about these people that as
they cut themselves it actually brings
pleasure rather than pain like somebody
else might be like oh i would never want
to do such a thing
and maybe it's just that they're
different so they've actually done
research to find out
what if they do certain things that are
physiologically
painful to people how does an individual
who is a cutter
or someone who self-harms how did how
did they respond
to it versus somebody that doesn't
struggle with this
so they've actually done the research so
there's something that that site
that psychologists use or researchers
and medical professionals use to cause
physical
painful stress to people that is
it's been you know empirically validated
so they know okay yes this works and
it's not like torture to the point where
you know because if you came up with
some really bad thing like we're gonna
do this very
terrible painful thing they'd be like
nope you're not going to do that study
that's illegal
right so this is called the cold presser
test and the cold presser test is
it's very simple anybody could do it but
they simply
they do this for tests to increase your
stress levels increase your pain without
hurting you
and what you do is you take a vat a
bucket
some kind of container with ice cold
water
and somebody has to stick their arm into
the ice cold water
until it physically hurts and as you do
that your blood pressure goes up
your heart rate will begin to go up the
stress response begins to kick in
and you feel simply pain
and stress so they thought well let's
see what happens and so in 2010
in in the journal of abnormal psychology
joseph franklin and his colleagues
they tried this first with people who
were cutters
sell people into self-harm and then
secondarily with the people who
were not and so what what they wanted to
find out
is it is it different for those who are
cutters and what they found out is that
when you
put somebody's arm till they're in pain
a cutter that
they actually when they pull it out that
it brings back a level of
uh well-being or happiness we might say
that is higher than before they put
their arm in the water
the painful water experience so it
actually increases their happiness
so
i mean the body wants homeostasis right
so it wants to like balance back
out yes so as it's balancing back out
then it goes ah well i feel better than
i did right here
exactly somehow exactly so you might
start here
then you go in there and the burning
actually makes them here
so they drop in their their well-being
but when they
when it comes back it doesn't come back
to here it comes back to here
so or wherever that is we're giving the
idea so they end up feeling better so
then
well now the question is what happens in
just your average person who isn't a
cutter
so what they discovered is that when
they put the average person there
they also felt better than they did
beforehand so they are not different
it's not as if anybody who you're
struggling issue may feel like i'm just
a different kind of person no
you've just found a coping mechanism
that makes you feel better
makes sense right very simple but the
difficulty is this coping mechanism is
also hurtful so thinking about that
uh you know you realize this is not
something that
you know if you had a child think think
about this maybe you
struggle with it or you know would you
want your own child
to do that right so sometimes it's like
it's okay for me because
i'm i feel down about myself i feel bad
about myself
i feel i'm ugly i feel people have put
me down or
or i've been abused or whatever it is it
doesn't even have to be those things
but i feel bad so it is okay for me
that if i had a child i hope they
wouldn't do that right
and so thinking about that well number
one
you are god's child and god loves you
with an everlasting love no matter
what's been done to you you
may feel dirty you may feel ashamed you
may feel ugly you may feel whatever
but there is a heavenly father who looks
down on you and he cares and he has his
son jesus who
who wants to set you free and we're
going to talk more about that but i want
to talk about the research
on this now it's interesting because
back in 2013
this same psychiatrist franklin and his
team
they found the same thing worked they
had been doing it for years but
i don't know why they had to do the
study again but sure enough have you
ever heard of shock therapy
it's actually electrocute the brain they
literally electrocute you
and my wife uh she was working in a
hospital
and she when she was in her clinicals
she was a part of it where
she would actually shock somebody you
know and you think kind of an
interesting thing to do
and she said i've never seen it happen
but i guess it's quite violent like it's
it's it's not like wow
you know it's like you know like an
intense ex
experience but the same thing happens
with that you go through this
traumatic painful experience but then
and often they may become
so it's so overwhelming to the body that
they become
tired for a couple days even like it's
it's intense but then they have a
you know you feel better afterward
there's people who have
bee stings people with arthritis they
will literally
take bees and sting them and
they will literally like take them in
some tongs and they will sting them and
they end up feeling
better afterward and so all of these
things just
give us a depiction of how our bodies
work
certain physiological things that cause
us pain and not only this
i've been depressed i think of
i went through 10 years of depression
i've shared that with here before
that 10 years of depression it was
terrible it was literally
man i i've also been beaten really good
i've had a couple of guys just
beat the living tower out of me and um
i deserved it i fully deserved it it was
good for me i needed it but
so these guys just beat the junk out of
me and i'll tell you if i could have a
choice between
a beating like that or depression i
would take a beating
every time yeah i mean like like the
depression is horrible
and so i think i can understand why uh
someone might struggle
with that because depression is so rough
and
but the good news is there are things we
can do to overcome that and
we have a whole video on here look back
and i don't even know what it's called
but
we have one on the got brain connection
i think a depression look it up
on on little lights youtube channel
overcoming depression overcoming
depression okay we have one on
overcoming depression check that out
and so i can totally understand why
someone would want that
but what are some things that we can do
what about
so i thought about this and the
psychiatrists or the scientists who did
this study
they didn't make this connection they
just said okay they were just trying to
figure out
how do average people don't do it
compared to people who do it and
then i i already knew about research on
this cold
type experience we have a term for using
hot and cold
what do we call it therapy hydrotherapy
now they didn't think about they're just
like oh there's a cold presser test
it works it's painful it doesn't hurt
you
it actually benefits you it increases
your you know psychological state
so i knew about some of the research
multiple studies had come out already
and so here's research from the journal
of medical hypotheses and this is just
like a
springboard study this particular one
but this is not the only study done on
it
but this just gives you the idea the
name of this study is adapted
cold shower as a potential treatment
for depression now think about this
so there's something called hydrotherapy
in the research they called a adapted
cold
shower many of us who've been doing it
for years some of us do it every time we
start feeling
sick right yeah it's kind of like i
think it's a 30
increase if you actually um um do it as
a habitual thing it it actually helps
your health by 30 not to get as sick
that like your immune function begins to
they have actually done research on it
and they found that
by doing this now the thing is do any of
you guys
like cold showers oh you sit there and
you think about it for a while and you
gotta psych yourself out you know and
then like
totally totally like it depends on how
early i wake up
i know i know about the research i know
when i'm feeling down i straight up do
this
and eat like when i say down i'm talking
about specifically you start feeling uh
like you're gonna get sick you're like
man i need and so just to tell you how
it works
it's it's called a contrast shower they
call it an adapted cold shower
what you do is you take a a hot shower
when i say hot don't burn yourself a
normal
warm comfortable shower and you do that
until you're ready and you're like
like you said psyched out and then you
turn it to like 30 seconds to a minute
cold and then you go back for a minute
on
nice and comfortably hot then 30 seconds
cold back and then 30 seconds and you
finish on the cold actually
and so this adapted cold shower can
actually do the same thing so
you you don't like it you hate it you're
like ah you're fine
but by the third time it's what it's
actually bearable yeah it's totally bare
the third time you're like oh this isn't
so bad but the first time it's horrible
the second time it's not fun and the
third time it's still not fun but it's
bearable and the irony is you know as we
get into the winter months right you
guys hate getting out of the
shower and it's like freezing outside
and you're like trying to heat up right
um you actually can just get out of the
shower and it feels great totally and
you can totally walk around like
wet hair everything like this and you're
like yeah this is awesome
it feels warmer outside than the cold
you were just in right but that's
interesting i've never thought of it
like you're actually like
worsening the body's situation so that
it like all of a sudden bounces back and
goes ah well at least it's not as bad as
that right
yeah totally and think about it and the
researchers didn't really make the
connection either they're just like oh
okay they're the same
everybody's the same we just feel better
after this but then i thought hey i
already knew the research on this and so
one of the things that we can do is so
yes
cutting makes us feel better but it's
also your body is a temple
of god the bible says that our body is
the temple of god and god loves you
and he says that your body's like a
temple so like you think of like a
church
and imagine if somebody came in and like
you know if you had a church and you
love your
church and you love your pastor and then
somebody comes in and just like defiles
it puts
filth in it and you know rips the
curtains and burns the place or whatever
you'd feel violated right and our body
is to be the temple of god and god says
specifically
do not he that he doesn't want us to
defile
his temple that's a good point because
we're special to him it's a really good
point
and that application can be like so many
other things too i mean just putting
junk
in it yeah it's like anything you know
you
i've never actually looked at it in that
way before but that's a great way to
look at it
yeah and i think that's something to
think about that you are
special you are special in god's sight
no matter how you feel about yourself
no matter what someone has said about
you somebody i just think we were
talking in our last
video about uh even young children
middle school they're sending
naked pictures of themselves to each
other and i hear these things
and it breaks my heart for them because
you know those things are going
everywhere
and imagine anybody not just for a
middle school anybody
you do these kind of things and then if
somebody puts you down imagine
imagine what it would be like the
vulnerability and there your picture is
out forever
and and the pain it can be and so i
simply say i know re
people are in a lot of pain and so these
kind of things people feel like can help
them
but god doesn't want you to file his
temple he wants to actually dwell inside
of you he wants to give you peace he
wants to give you joy
and fulfillment in life and
but here's the thing hydrotherapy taking
these adapted cold shower or what we
call contrast showers
these things are helpful they'll
actually make you happier and they'll
make you happier
like in a few minutes so it's not like
you have to wait a long time
but it is something you can do instead
of just like cutting
hurts but then you feel better this also
hurts but then you feel better but it's
also enhancing your immune function
right
so it's actually beneficial for your
health so doing this is beneficial
but one of the things i say is that it's
not a cure
it's a band-aid so just to understand is
it like a form of
deviation so you just need to pick the
better choice
so when someone's feeling sad and
depressed and they're within themselves
they're trying to deviate from that
emotional pain by causing
physical pain and they feel that
exhilaration but
a better way to do that to get out of
that funk would be to
take a shower is it sort of like when
you have a headache and your head is
pounding because
there's all that blood in your head so
you use hydrotherapy you put your feet
in cold water and the blood rushes to
your feet instead to
to calm your brain but i mean your feet
kind of hurt
as soon as like finding a healthy
deviation
or a distraction for lack of a better
word from the
the pain that you're feeling i think
that is part of it i think that is part
of it is that it so it is actually
number one it's not fun so it's giving
you kind of the same experience of
cutting because it's like
i hate this i don't like this you might
even actually hate the cold shower more
than cutting you know like
you're getting used to the cutting thing
but this might even be worse but it
actually has the benefit
there is the uh taking the place of
something and the good thing is once
again this takes the place of the bad
but this doesn't cure the problem itself
meaning it might temporarily it might
temporarily give you
like so you were here you're down and
then you're in the cold shower and
you're like
here you know and then and boom now
you're a little bit better
but there are other things we can do to
help overcome i'm not going to go into
all those we talked about some in the
in the last one and but another one that
fits very well with
cutting or self-harm is a form of
self-harm that can actually be
beneficial also and it's not really
self-harm
is exercise right exercise is another
experience that
i um so think about running do
most people actually enjoy the run
itself
no some do but most of us don't most of
us i know
when i run it's not the run that i like
it's what
it feels like from running totally so
you what do you have you have the
endorphin i mean they call it the
runner's high i don't know that i've
ever had the runners
or maybe it is maybe it's just i do feel
better after i don't feel like
wow but i feel better
yeah i feel better and so exercise is a
form of
like self-abnegation it's like the
flatulation or the torture
the self-torture but after the
self-torture you feel better
and so but this is one that actually has
also positive
positive effects rather than negative
effects and so
we we stated in one of the other videos
that it's not a
some believe in that kind of the yin and
the yang idea where
or where you have the light and the dark
and both dwell together in one
individual
and you just accept the good and the
evil but no
certain things are actually harmful
certain things are just not good and the
bible uses the term
temperance which is avoiding things that
are bad
all together all together you don't say
like i moderately use heroin
just from time to time i just use a
little right you know and right
it keeps me going you know it keeps me
on an even keel no like
moderation you don't use moderation like
all things in moderation
like not all things about right slogan
right there yeah yeah it's like no
that's not true so so what you do
temperance is better than just
moderation temperance is
avoiding the things that are bad and
moderately using things that are
good good because even a good thing
could you know water could kill you
right you can literally drink 10 gallons
a day and you will probably die
you eat too many carrots you will turn
orange that's true right it is literally
true that's not a joke right
and so so learning to even with exercise
you can overdo exercise too you can ruin
your joints you can do these kind of
things so
doing something that and that's why
somebody who might be a cutter or
someone who does some
form of self-harm burning other people
burn
that these things can yes they make you
feel bad but
you could do something and research
already shows they've done research
comparing three different things
comparing people taking zoloft a
depression medication
then they compared them to people who
exercise and it was the same study
who were depressed also and then the
third group was depression and zoloft
the drug medication so they did both
so three different groups and what they
discovered was
six months later each one of the groups
had people who were statistically
happier they were doing better
but strangely enough six months later
the group that was doing the worst were
the ones who are exercising
and on zoloft interesting why i don't
honestly know
why doing both is actually more
detrimental but
then the next group that was doing a
little better were the ones on the drug
medication
zoloft and the third group the ones that
did the absolute best i had the lowest
levels of depression
were simply those who were out
exercising and i bet they had cleaner
livers
yeah cleaner yeah exactly so your body's
just doing better so
in saying that doing the
doing the hydrotherapy is a band-aid but
regularly exercising because part of it
is this um
i know each of us work in video or
design and these kinds of things and
myself included
and because of that what is one thing
that can be difficult to do
yes yes i just walked out of the studio
here and i'm like
it's it's it's anytime it's sunny out
it's beautiful i'm like
here we are in a cave you know it's like
i mean you know watching it
live you're watching it you might think
like oh it looks you know fine in there
but but still it feels like a cave in
here right you know
yeah no windows exactly we were just
talking about that beforehand and
so thinking about that long story short
get living a healthy lifestyle getting
exercise we have to actually make a
decided effort to do it because
historically did people have to think i
need to get my exercise no
no the other plow on the field
totally like a friend of mine uh grow up
amish still lives the amish lifestyle
largely although they have a vehicle
but they plow their field with a horse
and and
they're just amazing you know their work
but so he never has to think like man i
gotta go to the gym yeah i gotta lift
weights yeah i gotta hit some i gotta
hit the weights it's like
no like when you're done with the day
you're done with the day like i'm going
in and
spending some time with the family and
um they don't have to worry about all
this
battlefield hollywood stuff you know uh
at least not like this and so you get
the idea
but humans just used to have they used
to live this way
you may be depressed and here's the
thing we all feel like our depression
is because of what's going on in our
mind and that seems logical
i've been thinking about this thing i'm
thinking about what happened in my past
and i'm depressed it's because of that
that's why i'm depressed
that is a factor and i'm not negating
that what has happened to all of us
does affect our mental state but when
our body is
functioning on a holistic
level like you had mentioned i was
equilibrium or
something like that yeah homeostasis
when our body is functioning at
homeostasis
stressors are less stressful
does that make sense so like for
instance if if you're carrying
a 100 pounds on your on your shoulders
and somebody puts 10 more pounds you
might give way
you know what i mean or like let's say
you have 200 pounds on your shoulder or
whatever you could bear just a little
bit more weight can be like
bam like knock you down and so
by not exercising by not living a
healthy lifestyle by
by not getting out in the sunshine by
not doing various different healthy
things
so the thoughts become overwhelming the
thoughts are like the
the feather that somebody drops on you
you think no it's not a feather chat it
crushes me what i think about
it does crush you and i'm not i know i
know what depression is like so none of
this is putting you down
if you feel this i i understand what it
feels like
but what i can say is this is that if
you can get your body in a healthy and a
healthy functioning manner
the that what it will become like wow
what used to literally crush me
isn't that big of a deal anymore and so
implementing
so exercise even the cold showers these
are important
one of the things that we talked about
on our video did we do one on the got
brain connection am i wrong
no we just talk about it a lot because i
i remember having a long discussion with
you about it and so i've brought it up
kind of
a lot and um but i think that you know
there was two videos though one was
overcoming depression the other one was
something and it was about diet yeah
okay yeah so we may have touched on but
this this particular you can see the
research there this is from the american
journal of public health actually
two different studies were conducted on
this exact subject
so the first one was smaller the second
one was larger and what it was was
one of them was in young people and the
other one was in
you know middle age normally like older
people and what they discovered was
is that depending on how many servings
of fruits or vegetables you eat in a day
that will it will statistically increase
your happiness your well-being or your
life satisfaction
that day but then it will forecast how
happy you are
the next day that's interesting and so
this is the actual chart check this out
so
on the left up and down is your level of
life satisfaction we might call that
happiness
on the bottom from left to right zero
you're at the lowest level of happiness
statistically and then as you eat one
there's a little blip you probably won't
notice
right and then two three four five
six seven eight servings of fruits or
vegetables in a day
and you become statistically a happier
person
and you become happier tomorrow i wonder
like if you think about this when you go
to a vacation spot like my idea of a
vacation is like sand
beach you sit there you do nothing but
drink coconut water and
you know whatever right but when you go
on a vacation like that you're not
sitting there thinking like all the
vegetables you're gonna eat right
you're thinking of the different fruits
that you're gonna eat and people
typically like
that vacation i don't know if that
actually has
i mean i could see this being totally
true you know what's interesting about
this i've seen this before
is um you think of the standard american
diet not a lot of fruits
not a lot of vegetables and you're
thinking you know i don't know
look how easy this is to start two a day
that's where you see your your absolute
greatest
gain from one to another
if you look at seven to eight it's not
as great of a gain as it is from one to
two or from two to three or three to
four your greatest gain is just
just go from one to two that's an easy
way to start just
just eat another fruit eat another
vegetable
eat another serving a bowl it's like a
handful and you're gonna see
a big increase that's such a great point
it's such a small ink
so some of you might be thinking like
eight servings of fruits or vegetables
like oh i could never do that but here's
the thing
you could probably eat two right and
you could start with one you might not
notice such a big difference two would
be better
at least two and you're on the way to
something better so i used to live in
california
fruit is amazing in california i'm sorry
east coasters like you guys have
no idea what real fruit tastes like
right
it's better well it's half india totally
yeah you have an idea for your from from
islands and stuff but
um i'm telling you it's totally
different on this side of the country
but
my wife actually was sharing with me um
you know
you can buy frozen fruit that is usually
frozen at its optimum
point yes so even though you say like
well i don't have access to fruit like
that yes but you can go buy frozen fruit
that is that access to that and some of
those frozen fruits will mix a whole
bunch of things like you can put
dragon fruit in with pineapple and
papaya and so you can get a couple of
different varieties
really easily and you're actually right
about that that research has shown that
some of the
now it's one thing if you live in
california pluck it from the tree
yourself that's as fresh as it's going
to be
but when it comes to frozen sometimes
for many of us frozen can actually be
fresher than fresh
because it may take weeks for it to
actually or
months when it comes to apples and
things like that to actually get to us
but when they freeze it they're freezing
it at its
uh and i'm not saying just to eat fresh
but you can almost
almost anywhere that's the good news so
so you can get to it
fairly easy you can put it in a smoothie
and it's easy you know that's true yeah
that's true
and think about this part of
each one of the things that we're
talking about is about
delayed gratification meaning
suffer now eat your fruit and vegetables
and then get a better experience but
here's the thing so i say that
and we all laugh because that's the way
many of us probably have thought at some
point in our lives i was not a big fruit
or a vegetable eater at all
i ate basically junk food refined food
and meat right
and so like every night at 11 o'clock at
night i would eat a box of macaroni and
cheese the whole thing with tabasco
sauce and every single spoonful
wow and so what i'm saying is like you
like well maybe there's some tomato
sauce in the tabasco sauce you know but
it's like
you get the point it's like cheese and
white flour and so it's not nutritious
and so you know you're just not as happy
and then when you transition to these
things you start feeling
like a different person and so what we
hope each one of these things
can be taking some of the load off your
back and then and then once again
as you take the load off your back then
even as those
negative memories and oppressive
thoughts that we go over and over and
over as
we become man our back starts to
straighten out and we're like
wow and then the thought comes back a
thought that used to just crush you with
depression
and you're like nope not going to think
about that now
i got my apples to eat or whatever you
know like you're going to go on feeling
better
and going on to the next subject so
on to the next subject which is
something that we oh go ahead
before you move on to that i i just want
to like encourage the viewer as well
test it test this i mean i mean honestly
it's one thing to be like whatever i'm
going to reject whatever you guys are
saying is talking about health
right try it just try it i mean it
really doesn't take a lot of energy or
effort
to just try it and if you're struggling
with those kind of thoughts
just put a couple of these things to to
test and do the daniel challenge you
know okay god i'm giving you 10 days
you got 10 days to make this thing work
yeah and that was so powerful about that
so in
uh dr esselstein who is one of the
three scientists that i know of that
have shown that you can reverse heart
disease which we had talked about before
an atheist and he's an atheist but he
did us he did one but he gives
he did a study on this actually two
different studies showing that you could
reverse
heart disease but and one of them i find
very interesting because you mentioned
the number
10 days and the reason that's there is
because in daniel chapter 1
there in which is in the bible in the
old testament there's a young man named
daniel
he was taken captive in from his
hometown of jerusalem taken to babylonia
which is in modern day iraq
my wife comes from iraq and while he was
there he was forced into a three-year
educational system
and he he didn't want to eat their meat
because it could have been meat that the
bible said not to eat
and so what he did was he said to the
leader hey can can we just eat plant
foods
and the guy's like man they might kill
me if i don't have you eat the king's
meat the king's meat is the best food in
the world
and so daniel's like how about we test
it and did you know
that scientific historians medical
historians i should say medical
historians tell us
that is the oldest scientific study in
all of recorded history
so daniel and his friends say okay 10
days
let's test it see what happens and
you're like come on what's going to
happen changing to a plant-based diet
for 10 days come on that's not going to
make that big of a difference
esselstein mind you it was a mix between
i think they did drug medication within
the 10 days too but they put this dude
on
his cholesterol which was like 247
which is in the clearly in the heart
attack range if you get
under 150 your total cholesterol under
150 you're nearly in a heart attack free
range
and this dude got it from like 247
to like right around 149 in exactly
10 days on a plant-based diet he did use
cholesterol loading medication
but we did the same thing with i won't
say who it is with someone that's close
to
my wife and myself and this person also
they struggled and struggled and tried
to eat a healthier diet we put them on a
whole food plant-based diet
and they were able to get their
cholesterol down into the healthy range
within one month i mean we're not i mean
we weren't we didn't have it tested
within 10 days but the point is
the change can take place even with your
happiness with it
very rapidly yeah so esselstyn
interesting about him because i've read
his book
he um he got all the patients that
nobody else
wanted at cleveland uh medical clinic
we give up on these people and so he was
like
okay and he decided to do something
different because he's friends with
uh t colin campbell who he's doing some
research on plant-based diet
and so he's like okay we'll try this
thing and so they put
i mean it was intense what they put
those people through
but even years later he had not
lost a patient and keep in mind all
these people had a prior cardiac event
stroke heart attack something like that
right
bypass i mean they're in bad shape one
foot in the grave another on a banana
peel right
and he um he had these people record
everything they ate
and he told him like no i mean he was
strict i'm not suggesting this is for
everybody
he's like no oils of any kind no nuts no
avocados
nothing like you can't have any oils
because all oils are a mixture of
saturated unsaturated fat and
you didn't want to get the saturated fat
but anyway it was convincing enough what
he saw these people go through
he went home and he's like we're
changing our lifestyle
and told his family his kids he's like
we're doing this like
i want to save your lives he's an
atheist
doesn't have any you know religious
experience he's like no
this is gonna help your life and i'm
going to extend your life and help save
your life and his son
is the one that went on to create the
engine 2 diet
cook a book and cookbook and he's a
firefighter and helps
go around all over helping firefighters
get
healthier because they're under a lot of
stressors
this is brought out in forks over knives
some of it's in forks over knives but
the other is
in his book which is how to prevent and
reverse heart disease yeah but forks
overnight says a great
yeah like explanation for the heart
disease part anyway yeah it does and
so something to consider it changed my
life i actually went on this diet for a
time and
by the way one of the things that it
also did for the guys in the study
they're older these guys are probably
70s 60s
and it reversed their e.d
good news because remember the the
ed erectile dysfunction is one of the
main causes the driving factors is that
the arteries the penile arteries
begin to clog and as they begin to clear
that up
and it happens very quickly which is the
amazing thing so as they did that
it actually fixed that problem so they
were very very thankful what most people
don't understand is when you have
symptoms of heart disease it's not just
your heart it's
everywhere it's happening in your entire
body
and so the ed is actually a symptom
that's right
and do you go to the doctor complaining
about that that's one of the things he's
going to look at
is well what is your cholesterol what is
going on in the rest of your body
because you're experiencing heart
disease
more than likely isn't the human body so
amazing and by extension
god our creator is so amazing you put
the right stuff in it'll respond right
amazing though that you can operate the
human body putting junk in it like
try try that with your car yeah you know
go drive around with candy bars and
and red bull in your car and see how far
it goes it will not go very far
so on top of eating right and
by the way you can do this this is
something that can rapidly make a
difference you can make a slow
transition eating a couple things today
if it's too late at night go to bed skip
that start tomorrow
and and then you can add a couple more
and in time get up to your eight
servings a day and feel better than
you've maybe felt in your whole life
so that's one factor though but the next
one is
sleep sleep is
very nice very it's very nice
and this is actually probably a struggle
for even like religious people
like you know even even doctors and
things struggle with this one because
it's just like
you're just trained to operate with no
sleep or little sleep or whatever
um i mean even parents that that you
know barely get any sleep and constantly
complain about this i mean this is a
this is a major issue
it really is i'll tell you what it where
this one makes the most sense to me is
if you have kids like you know this
better than all get out
there's a reason parents are like i've
got to get my kids
in bed by a certain time because they
know they all know
if those kids do not get enough sleep
the next day is completely
different right good point good point so
that is so true it's it's so evident if
you're a parent
like and and you think about yourself
even as a parent like if the kid's not
getting enough sleep
i watched my wife go through this for a
long time uh she wasn't getting enough
sleep you know and you just how much
that
compound effect you know wears on
everybody
everyone walks around with horns you
know
i think about what you're saying is and
we think
chad i'm old it doesn't affect me like
it does
my kids and yeah you can put on a better
face than the kids and you can try to
because you got a
fully developed frontal lobe if you're
over 25 years old
and so you can really put on the show
that it doesn't affect you
but it affects you right so so you think
like ah that's not the factor for me
but getting to bed when is a good time
for a kid to go to bed
before nine yeah right for kids it's
like man if you get them to bed by eight
they'll be like angels the rest of their
life you know
not necessarily but you know for but you
get
humans to bed even adults between nine
and ten and nine is even better
if you really want to be the happiest
you can be consistently going to bed
by nine o'clock is fantastic for your
mental health
and so when i do that and i know i used
to stay up
two three in the morning like i said i'd
eat mac and cheese at
11 o'clock and i'd stay up till two in
the morning every night and i'd sleep at
school
and it was just i just wasn't happy and
then
i ended up going to i gave my life to
jesus my life was changed and then i
went to a school
and my roommate i was like i'll just do
whatever he does
he when he was at in bed by nine nine
thirty we were asleep and i was like
whatever he does
and he'd wake up at five in the morning
and crack his bible
i just thought whatever he does i'll do
it and at five in the morning the light
turned on and i look over what does he
do he didn't even get out of bed
he i mean he doesn't stand up he just
rolls out of bed and starts praying i
was like all right that's what i'm gonna
do
and i just rolled up and started praying
and then uh and then he's like right
when he was dying he started reading his
bibles like all right i'll read my bible
it's five in the morning
and then he read his bible until eight
o'clock and went to breakfast i was like
all right read the bible for three hours
and so we did that the whole time and i
was like
you know praise the lord i had that
roommate
i felt during those months with that
actually i ended up getting another
roommate uh because that one was only
there for two weeks
i got another roommate and five o'clock
i did what everybody
does right flips on the light and
scrolls it down and starts praying you
know because that's what you do here
and so so you know what my new roommate
did yeah he rolled out of bed too he
started praying you know
and i didn't think about it till years
later oh he probably did that because i
did it because the other dude did it
so we can all be impacting somebody
around us
but long story short i felt like a
champion
a champion because of that and you may
think putting these things together
remember
each one of these things if you
implement is taking like
40 pounds off your back each time you're
taking 40 pounds off your back
so that those mental stressors will
become
later like a feather that's what we're
hoping to do so that we have no
desire to self harm that's what we're
hoping
now uh another thing before you move on
thing with the shower taking cold shower
hot shower
first time is terrible by the third time
it's bearable
the same with waking up early the first
time i mean you roll over
before you even say dear jesus you're
back to sleep right but you keep doing
that
it gets easier it gets better i love
that sister that is and
and that that is a point to that with
each one of these things the first time
you do them
is the worst so for instance if you're
not used to eating any fruits and
vegetables
literally if you're used to eating like
twinkies and that kind of stuff
you eat an apple after a twinkie and
it's like
tasty yeah why didn't you eat these yeah
like who would eat an apple
but when you have like you know a peanut
butter sandwich
with you know healthy you know peanut
butter and some whole grain
bread and then you you bite into an
apple and you're like wow
that's really good that's fantastic you
know and so the point is
it's making transitions it's making
transitions and as you do
they get easier and at some point you
begin to just love doing them
yeah so the food that i eat now which i
didn't i'm on a total plant-based diet
now
i eat so esselstyn finally said he's
like okay you can have one ounce of nuts
a day initially it was no nuts
whatsoever
and later on he's like okay one one
ounce of nuts a day
so what is that like two almonds it's a
whole handful it's waterproof
it's funny because uh friend scott ritmo
was over and his wife was like so how i
i told him it's 40 grams the research
shows
and we're like well let's she's like how
much is that exactly and we're like well
we got a scale right here we pull out
the
you know almonds and and we measure and
it was and they say a handful it was
exactly a handful
so if you want to know the research
shows that one
ounce or one handful of nuts
will give you all of the cognitive or
the brain benefits
and any more than that adds no no
cognitive benefit
so that is like when it comes to it that
amount is good
any you know if you're looking to lower
cholesterol
keeping it at that no higher would be
better but we're not talking about i
think there's a reason why god made a
walnut look like a brain
yes it does things like that you know it
totally looks like a little horse
yeah yeah eat this it'll be good for
your brain
so next point in our list of things that
may help with
self harm a doctor friend of
mine that i'm guessing you've either all
heard of is dr
neil nedley you've heard natalie so dr
nedley is
in my estimation one of the greatest
doctors in the world and
he has amazing both
the research that they do and working
with people with depression and so forth
and one of the things he points out is
most all of the people that come into
his clinic
struggling with depression also struggle
with
pornography interesting and if you
struggle with that watch our last
two episodes right we did two episodes
on that you're not going to want to miss
that
but one of the things i would challenge
you to do if you are
unmarried or you struggle with
pornography is
cease consumption of those things and
your brain may begin to heal
it's just another one of those burdens
those weights that you're
stacking up on your back there's an old
story from
500 years ago literally uh called the
pilgrims progress
and it is an amazing that book it was
the most popular book in america
next to the bible wow for many years for
many years because it's just it's like
blow your mind good
have gone through it multiple times and
and in the pilgrim's progress it's the
story of a guy named christian
who has a in it in the you know
elizabethan tongue he has a burden that
lieth hard upon his back
meaning he has a heavy heavy heavy
weight on his back whatever's in it
we're never told but it's
very very heavy and he's walking around
and life
is a burden and you know there's even
like in the drug culture there's the
monkey on your back illustration you're
walking around with a monkey on your
back so everybody's kind of used this
illustration
and so at this point we're trying to
take the monkey off of our back we're
trying to take this sack off of our back
and the good news for christian
uh his life was changed when he came to
the cross he came to the cross
and the pack this weight began to fall
off
and rolled away the burden rolled away i
mean interesting that jesus used that
illustration of you know like take my
yoke it's
light give me your burdens i'll take
them away
and he he takes them all and so we'll
get back to that too and that's exactly
it
and so but i would challenge you one
other burden is the sexual burden
watch the videos we did on sexuality
because it's not just porn you may not
struggle with porn you're like oh porn's
not my thing i just love having sex with
people
and uh you know but we show the research
on that too and that also
having out of marriage sex the research
shows that
especially when it is things like one
night stands increases the chances of
depression so
separating yourself from these things
and
by doing so you're letting go of that
burden you start feeling lighter you
start feeling better it'll take time at
first
it may be a struggle but we tell you
more on how to do that and some of that
is the same things here so so i would
challenge you to stay away from sexual
relations for a time there's so much
packed into that phrase
as christian looked to the cross his
burdens
rolled away or when people say look to
jesus or you know all you need is jesus
well yes but it means so much more than
that where do you find jesus
in the bible yes and every single
principle you laid out
can be found in god's word so it's not
just like standing there looking at the
cross or standing there looking at jesus
it takes work it's very practical and
what is meant by that phrase
is dive into the word of god and
transform
your life or you help accept his help in
transforming your life yeah thank you i
appreciate that i mean
just going over that someone could miss
out on that it is not just looking at a
cross on a church or on a building on a
wall
or on your neck or whatever it is but it
is actually spent timing
looking at the life of jesus seeing what
he has done for us
seek and you'll find him right yeah
that's right you've got to look look
look and
god will reveal himself that's right and
he says and you shall seek me and you
shall find me when you shall search for
me
with all your heart and he wants to set
us free and so
you know the healing is through both
the mind and body we think once again
i i thought during my depression that it
was
basically the thoughts that were my
problem that it's the thoughts that are
my problem
and i'm not negating the thoughts
because the thoughts are a problem and
they affect our physiology
but once again and i keep illustrating
it the burden on your back which could
be physiological
which often is because even dr nedley's
program
most of this program he does do
cognitive behavioral therapy cognitive
behavioral therapy that is a
key component very important component
but much of it is physiological
it is changing the diet it is getting
exercise every day it is getting on the
sunlight and if you can't get out in the
sunlight what would you do
you can buy one of those lamps right
yeah you can buy these lamps
specifically like amazon
tanning
those vitamin d pills yeah vitamin d
vitamin d is a potential option also
and so the the lights do something even
different the lights
actually don't give you the vitamin d
but vitamin d might be a benefit if
you're a low in vitamin d to take the
pill
but as far as the boxes they just get
hit have the light hit your eye
and help you get your body back to that
homeostasis that
the way you feel after being out in the
sun even though it doesn't actually
uh do the same thing as the sun does so
one of the one of the things the mind
and the body are connected
and one of my favorite one of my
favorite quotes here and we're just
about to finish
is that this mind transformation quote
never forget that
thoughts work out actions
repeated actions form habits and habits
form character and so this kind of
summation of all of
uh mental psychology not necessarily
physical psychology things that are
connected to the body but mental
psychology is summed up in this thought
that
never forget that the things you think
about the thoughts you have when you
they become actions the repeated actions
become habits and the habits become your
character
and this can be true with your thoughts
and as you begin to
change your physical habits as you begin
to
change your physical habits as you
repeat those new physical habits
they'll become a new you know habit that
becomes a new part of your character
so as you start eating better it will
become as normal as eating junk food
right so and preferably you'll start to
back off the junk food
but it will become just as normal and
the good news is
your taste buds change so you end up
enjoying the healthy food
every bit as much as you enjoy the junk
food
it's really amazing that like i love
food in my simple plant-based diet that
i eat now i love it every
much as i loved the junk food that i
used to eat
but i actually enjoy it better and it
changed my mind and my body and i feel
good afterward and i don't feel like i
shouldn't eaten that you know like
you feel better and so the changes will
take place
allow your mind to be changed because
you won't be changed
just by trying to change your actions
and
god can actually be a part of healing
the mind and that's what
mark chapter 5 we talked about this man
who was
by the sea side there's actually two of
them but in this in this text it says
always night and day this man was in the
mountains and the tombs crying
cutting himself with stones but then it
has a beautiful word and
often when you see this word in the
bible something good comes after and
it's the word but
so here he was cutting himself with
stones crying out the guy's just
totally unhappy but it says
but when he saw jesus
afar off he ran and worshiped him
he didn't even know who jesus was as far
as i know i doubt he knew him
but when he saw him there was something
in his soul that said that that man
has the answers to all of the things
that are going on in my heart
what a beautiful thought that that man
right there
he may have dirty feet from walking down
the dusty roads with those sandals
he has rough hands from working years
and years of a carp at a carpenter's
bench
but that dusty man with those rough
hands he has
exactly what my soul has been looking
for
and you know what jesus
really does have the answers and i knew
that when i was depressed i knew jesus
was the answer i spent time with him
daily
but i still felt guilty i felt just
totally guilty i was totally depressed
and but once again as my physical health
began to change
then my mental health the same thoughts
some of those same thoughts
or temptations would come to my mind but
because the physical burden was gone
the mental burden was okay i just bring
that to god simple as that leave it be
and go on with my day and i'll be happy
and so jesus healed this man
he healed a man that was was a cutter
and jesus can heal you
and he can also because you might be
like i can't take a cold shower
i can't eat apples i can't
get on exercise i'm too depressed
because sometimes people are too
depressed and i say
none of this to be funny there are
people who are so depressed they can't
get out of bed
they cannot get out of bed they are
people go years
maybe just going to the bathroom simply
and
god can help you just where you are and
as he helps you
once he gives you the strength to maybe
add an apple to your diet doesn't have
to be an apple whatever you like pick
the fruit you like to begin with right
you can even eat things like dates
i love dates we just had some today
they're very very good even simple
things like that
even dried fruit i got a whole i got a
whole video on
dried food if you want to know a dried
fruit healthy go watch the video but
uh it's powerful information on that so
this is the thing by doing these things
point by point
one thing at a time your life will be
changed and you can get to the point by
god's grace where you don't even
feel you don't need to cut yourself
and what we mean is this is that if you
feel good
you would never do it and god wants to
bring us to that point but you are his
temple
and he wants to dwell on you good point
two misconceptions
one i can't eat healthy it's too
expensive i disagree it's actually
cheaper than the other lifestyle why
because you're saving on a hospital bill
that's one two i can't exercise and do
these shower things i don't have any
time
i would say wow well really if you don't
have time for yourself you shouldn't
have time for anyone
or anything else because if you yourself
are unhealthy anything else that you do
would be unhealthy and counterproductive
so it's really like a
shift in priorities i think it's really
key that we take
time to make sure our temple is clean
before whichevers take out the moat
or the beam in your eye before you talk
about or
try to help the person with the moat in
theirs in in another way
work on ourselves so we can be the best
that we can be for other people
wow in this story with this person the
way that matthew i like how matthew kind
of even illustrates it out like the two
men were sitting at the feet of jesus
and then of course when they're getting
up and leaving
from the people telling them hey you
need to leave because you know
we're scared of what you just did we
hear these two men are in their right
mind
and the men go well take us with you and
god said jesus says no you know
stay here and go and tell people what
you've done all of a sudden
they were immediately in a situation now
where they were going to turn around and
bless other people
yeah not only were they scary in other
people but now they're going to go
actually bless them
with with leading them to jesus so i
think the same thing
can happen with you as well you know
depression totally you may
feel so depressed that you can't see
other people it's all
wrapped up in your world but the second
that that you get freed from that
it's like god can use you now to go and
unchain other people from that situation
that's a beautiful point you know oh
please okay i just want to share a
little bit
yeah before i change my lifestyle and my
diet
and i had some issue with anger but then
i
changed and i guess some of my friend
noticed how i was
in well i was here but they they're just
asking like how can you stay
you know stay happy and then you get
enough sleep even
even though you're in college so and
then i share to them
why why i can't be like this
and when they actually see the result
they're more likely to follow what
wow you're doing that's awesome and
you know this is my last point that
jesus went through
he was cut i mean he literally was
lacerated with whips he was beaten
he had a crown of thorns put upon him
and you think of the whip the whip
wasn't like a standard whip would be
insanely painful
like could you imagine someone a man
with a roman soldier with all of his
might
whipping you as hard as he could 40
times
minus one because they would do minus
one because if they
did one more they would actually go to
jail they would be punished themselves
for doing 40 or if they would go about
40. so they would do 39 just in case
they messed up
and jesus went through this but on the
end of those whips
an archaeologist friend of mine shares
with me that they'd put like shards of
bone or maybe glass and they would have
these on the end so these are literally
ripping into the back lacerating
the back of jesus while he you know they
put this crown of thorns on his head
he's going through all of this
and the bible has this amazing statement
in isaiah chapter 53 it says
with his stripes
we are healed with what he went through
so his the cutting that was done to him
in essence
heals us and one of the things that
jesus does one of the ways that we are
healed in our lives from
abuse as children or from any difficulty
is to look at the life of jesus
go through the gospels think through his
life spend time reading them and see how
his experience
is the experience that you go through
and we're actually healed through the
suffering in his life
we are some we we are healed it's as if
it's as if the whip comes down on his
back
lacerates his back and then the
laceration in our back
disappears like what a beautiful picture
and so jesus went through the suffering
so you don't have to he wants you to
have eternal life
he wants you to have peace in your heart
he wants to set each one of us free and
he can do exactly that so
wherever you are right now you can give
your life to jesus you can say jesus
i need something more to this life i
need something to get me through
something much better than than cutting
or
self-harm and whatever avenue jesus i
need you to change my life
and please jesus give me strength to
implement some of these simple
principles
to take the burden off my back if you've
heard this today and you're one of those
people that's struggling with this
there's a lot of people struggling with
depression uh you know just like chad
said he's been there done that i've been
there
done that it's it's rough and sometimes
you know you see this information and
you need somebody to help walk you
through that
contact us we have resources in this
area where i know a
couple and that they teach these very
same things he's a doctor
his wife is going to school to be a
counselor they go to my church
and they help people get through these
things using the same methods that we've
been talking about today
so if you feel like you need some extra
help you want somebody to walk with you
through that
they can help you do that so contact us
through our website little
lightstudios.tv
click on the contact us there's a forum
that'll come to me and we'll point you
in the right direction other than that
thank you chad for coming
again where can people get a hold of you
and your ministry it is
what's the website so our website is
anchorpointfilms.com
and our youtube channel if you want to
learn more about these things
is called health and homestead it's a
mixture so just look up
health and homestead and it's a mixture
of healthy principles to live a
healthier life happier life
and also country living and homesteading
all right
so check out those resources if you do
you'll likely be happier you also make
chad happy for checking out his
resource that he's putting together just
to help people
and so we thank you for watching this
episode uh
again we just want to encourage you guys
just try it
you know we're saying take take one step
at a time
do things give it those 10 days and see
if it makes a difference in your life
and trust god through the process so
thanks for watching make sure you like
comment and subscribe and
share this video with somebody who needs
it we'll catch you on the next episode
and this has been led live
visit our brothers at school for profits
dot tv and watch from babylon to america
which has over 5 million views on
youtube alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
this and more
[Music]
you